- I always like to finish up the hour
with something fun from social media.
Here's today's what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
When it comes to travel,
there are endless unique
experiences to be had,
but have you heard, because I hadn't
of lodging in a six ton potato?
It's a real thing, people,
you can do in where
else, but Boise, Idaho.
It's amazing.
We have the creator of this potato hotel
on the line watching on
Boise, Idaho News 6 at 4.
Let's say hi to Kristie.
Oh my god.
- Hi Kelly.
- Oh my god, I love you so much.
This is so cool and different.
How did you come up with this?
- This potato actually
was a promotional prop
by the Idaho Potato Commission.
So it has traveled many, many miles
on the back of a semi
truck going to festivals
and fairs all over the country.
And I was a spokesperson
for two years with it.
When they finally decided
that they needed to upgrade
to a more like roadworthy fiberglass one
they actually gifted me this
and I turned it into an Airbnb.
- Oh my God, look at the inside of that.
What? You should have
a design show, ma'am.
That was so cute.
So, what types of people rent
out a giant potato to stay in?
- Well, this is was I
think my fourth Airbnb
and I didn't know if it
would actually be as popular
but luckily people like
to stay in the potato
as many people like to eat potatoes.
So we have road trippers.
The gal that stayed last night
had a potato themed
manicure set for the stay.
We've had weddings and we've even have,
I know at least one baby
that was conceived here
and they nicknamed him Tater Tot.
- Oh my gosh.
See I actually wanna have that,
I just wanna meet the people
that stay in this potato.
I just think that would be a fun hang
'cause it's hilarious and it's awesome.
And honestly, you have really
great interior design skills.
That was really, really cute.
Thank you so much, Kristie.
I'm liking your post right now.
- [Kristie] Thank you.
- All right.
And that's not all, ma'am.
Our season long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of Friction, the go-to erasable pen
of The Kelly Clarkson Show
want to celebrate those creating
fearlessly just like you.
So they're gonna give you $1,000.
- Are you freaking kidding?
- Oh my God, I love you so much, Kristie,
you have made me so happy today.
Thank you so much
to all our guests this hour,
Sarah Hyland, Natasha Leggero,
Courtney Rich, Alicia Brown,
Erica, Donna, Gary Brode,
Morgan Fogarty and all our
friends at WCCB Charlotte CW.
Y'all have a great day,
and if it's not, try and change it.